hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful and crazy game known as the
Boston immortal game this game was a
suggestion from a subscriber and you
know if you're from Boston you should
definitely know this game by heart it's
a you know very nice way for you to to
impress your family and friends or you
know just walk into a bar draw up a
chess board and you impress everyone by
showing them the immortal Boston game
the game was played in 1892 between
Franklin Knowles young and as a person
called
L door I haven't found any information
on this person or a photo of him and
this is the only this is the only game
ever played that is available in the
database by mr. L door so I believe it's
a it's a casual game it's not a
tournament game or anything but it's
also a very interesting game and before
we check it out we do have a photo
challenge and this will not be an easy
photo challenge as this photo challenge
consists of three questions so let's
check it out
question number one who is the world
champion observing the game being played
for that you get only one point four
extra points you have to guess who the
Grandmaster behind the world champion
also observing the game is and for some
extreme points who are the players who
are actually playing the game the two
gentlemen they're so best of luck to
everyone and for this video there there
are a couple of special photos as well
they were sent to me by a subscriber
Phillip from Marion he had a wedding day
and on his wedding day they managed to
play a game of chess him and his best
man Martin so here are a couple of
photos there are the two of them playing
chess we do have also a nice close-up of
the board a very nice board and a very
nice position indeed here we also have
another photo here also a nice close-up
of the position and as I'm sure a lot of
you noticed the cat here is a nice
close-up of the cat as well so there's
the cat so that being said let's check
out this game the Boston immortal game
so Franklin knows jung-hee he was known
to be a very strong player a chess
author as well and well some sources
some sources say that he defeated
players like will
Tiny's your highness to craft art and
even Harry Nelson Pillsbury but some
sources not so much some say that the
games were drawn so I will add a link in
the description below bye bye Edward the
winter to chess history calm so you can
check it out and read some more about
Franklin always young but this game is a
is very interesting and since we had so
much modern game chess in in my previous
videos it will be very nice to relax
with a nice classic so let's check it
out
Franklin knows young opens the game with
E 4 we have E 5 d 4 the central game he
captures on d4 and now C 3 the Danish
gambit D captures on C 3 Bishop to c4
offering another pawn and now Knight to
f6 C capture some V 2 is also playable
here sometimes most of the times you
don't want to grab too much material you
know a special like in the Evans gambit
you don't want that third pawn but here
it's actually perfectly right as this
runs into a very forced variation that
will more often than not result in a
draw Hereafter nice to have 6 sorry here
after this d5 has to be played and then
after Bishop captures Knight f6 here
white will temporarily win a queen after
king capture squink after sandy 8 and
then after Bishop to b4 check of course
you don't want to block this with the
bishop or denied you have to block it
back with the Queen then black will have
to give up his piece or that Bishop will
be the rock will grab the bridge 28 and
here it's a pretty pretty drawn game
after rook e8 night is coming to a3 you
know a pretty force the drive line but
if someone stronger than you place this
against it with the white pieces you
know don't be afraid to do it but in
this game Knight to f6 was played we
have Knight to f3 and now Knight
captures on e4 so grabbing a further
grabbing material and oh no this this is
the second move mister L door made by
this night for those of you who are
maybe new to this channel whenever I
cannot find a photo or any information
about a person I will use a photo of the
hoodie guy and as usual in honor of the
hoodie guy I am doing this video in a
hoodie so mr. nosy Anka castles
and 936 so a third move with this night
now seemingly coming with a tempo on the
bishop here we have night captures on c3
so a piece sacrifice already but that's
a that's a piece and this Knight has to
make its fourth move to actually grab
this piece so this is the fourth move by
this night I will have rook to e1 check
now comes Bishop to e7 and now Knight to
d5 the threat of course being capturing
the bishop on e7
we have Knight to c6 mr. L door defense
the bishop and now comes Bishop to g5
simply yet again attacking the pin piece
we have f6 blocking and this is in fact
the strongest move by L door now comes
Rock the c1 attacking this Knight and
here we have b5 defending this b5 is the
first mistake mr. elder makes better
would be something like nice to b6
getting the night away without actually
wasting such a move and also coming with
an attack on this night and after rook
captures here Knight captures and after
knife captors on c7 would check simple
King to f7 and after Knight captures
Knight captures and you can see that
white doesn't have any compensation as
he does have he does have he's a piece
down so not really not really going well
for white here so after rook to see one
black played b5
now comes rope captures on c4 as both of
these Knights were defending d5 square
mr. Noah was young once only this night
to be defending me v square we have B
captures on c4 and now comes Knight to
e5 and this is a very interesting a very
interesting line so what do you do here
black I still completely find and in
fact black is better here but what do
you play here well you can play F
captures on e5 this is actually
perfectly fine but this is what you
would get you would get Knight captures
on e7 Knight captures on e7 and now rook
captures on e5 and there's no no real
good way to defend it the night here but
you don't really care you play rook f8
and now after rook captures the Queen
will simply capture and after Bishop
capture skin captures and black will
have two rooks and the bishop against
the Queen black is winning here
on the other hand even if you don't play
F captures on e5 if you play King to f8
immediately getting out of the pin again
you will get night chapters only seven
night captures and now Queen to f3
simply locking this but you don't care
as Queen captures on a it is yet another
threat but here you have a bishop to b7
this is the move you have to find if you
want to go into this line would came to
f8 now after Queen captures d5 and again
black is much better here white doesn't
really white it doesn't really have
compensation so after Knight to e5 we've
seen you can play this you can play this
but what's black played that you cannot
play a black played F captures on g5 now
we have Queen to h5 check the only good
move that really continues the attack
for white here of course you can go King
to a faith because this runs into Queen
to f7 checkmate so you do have to block
the Queen's check g6 now comes Knight to
f6 this again comes with the check again
you cannot play you can flick him to a
fate because Queen to h6 is now
checkmate
so after Knight to f6 Bishop captures on
f6 is played and now comes Knight
captures on g6
this opens the discovered check from the
rook now moving the King would be the
best idea here but regardless of what
you play the game is pretty much over
for black hair black decided to give
back the material and rook captures on
e7 was played and here the best move you
can do is actually move the King into d8
but also you can capture with the night
if you play Knight captures then you get
this pretty much forced variation Knight
captures on h8 would check we have
Knight to g6 blocking now Knight
captures on g 6h captures and Queen
captures on g6 checking the King but
also attacking the bishop and the only
way to prevent losing the bishop is king
to e7 but then this runs in the Queen e4
check and now you will lose the rook and
black does not have compensation for the
Queen King moves Queen captures on a8
and now white is winning this game
but after this rook captures on e7 black
played Bishop captures on e7 and this
now runs into a forced checkmate in four
so feel free to
was the video here I will give it a
couple of seconds as usual for you to
decide it it's a very nice idea
especially for those of you who are
maybe new to chess who haven't seen it
yet so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are you know
an excellent attacker and you've
achieved quite quite a lot with
smothered mate so and for those who just
want to enjoy the show here nice to e5
that's the idea
creating a discovered check from the
Queen of course if King too afraid then
Queen to f7 is the immediate checkmate
and if King moves then we have the very
nice Knight to f7 check King moves
Knight here checks again King to f8 runs
into Queen to f7 checkmate King has to
move and now of course the move you have
to find in order to find this idea Queen
to e8 this finishes the game rock
characters and the knight to f7 a nice
smother checkmate
so that's that's the game the Boston
immortal game I do hope you enjoyed it
it features a lot of lovely elements
even though blacks defense wasn't you
know the greatest at all times it's a
casual game and you know it's from 1892
so a very nice classic so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I sure did as you know we covered so
much so many modern games that a nice
classic is you know more than welcome
and I would like to thank Mark Cammy and
Daniel Parker for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
I will have to check has some of your
other suggestions as well and you know
if you know if you're from Argentina by
any chance the best of luck today in in
the world's Cup and yeah I also wanted
to say I received my Kindle today so if
any of you have any very interesting
books that have increased your vast
knowledge feel free to suggest them in
the comment section below
you know I do want to increase my vast
knowledge as well so yeah and once again
thank you all and I will see you soon